on agira vous connaissez très bien cette
région vous avez couvert ce conflit et
d'autres pour le figaro est ce que vous
croyez effectivement que tu as milk
n'est pas près de se disparaître en tout
cas peut-être pas géographiquement mais
idéologiquement
d'abord il faut que quand est ce que
vous avez dit josé les forces syriennes
se sont les fds les forces démocratiques
cn qui sont pas les forces syriennes du
gouvernement de dalles bacha et les
forces les fds donc les forces
démocratiques cn sont en très grande
partie sont en fait des forces kurdes
mais avec quelques arabes parce que
comme jaca est une ville arabe
on va confier aux arabes la police de
rackham et enfin la force de frappe qui
a repris rakkas est une force jaune avec
les officinaux avec l'un des amériques
les algeco merci pour cette précision
devrait être cette correction ballon le
nom mais bon on comprenne bien voilà non
mais évidemment c'est parce que c'est la
fin c'est une c'est une politique assez
intelligente de la part des américains
de cette famille vraiment en première et
en deuxième en deuxième rideau si vous
voulez et d'avoir suscité ces fds et
forces démocratiques syriennes le qui ça
se passe assez bien
on ne va pas du tout vers un kurdistan
parce que par ailleurs vous avez un
échec total de la politique de base
années en irak
on pourra y revenir mais c'est un petit
peu compliqué mais on va vers des
américains qui ont su où il faut leur
reconnaître susciter les forces locales
pour éliminer dette mais bien sûr que
les
les dialyses savent s'évanouir dans la
nature
save disparaître pour pour réapparaître
ailleurs alors très un moment ait quitté
ils ont beaucoup quitter la série pour
resurgir en libye moment même il leur
suffisait de prendre turkish airlines et
à l'e3 le vol east en réseau home
istanbul tripoli aujourd'hui on fait
attention à cette fille aime et qui
existait il ya d'autres postes qui vont
ce que se constituer mais c'est une
première victoire mais je suis d'accord
avec grand avec un autre genre c'est
c'est une c'est une guerre de 100 ans et
une guerre de c'est une guerre de
civilisation c'est d'une guerre profonde
c'est une guerre très important parce
que c'est une guerre aussi d'éducation
alors vous avez des gens qui ont essayé
de faire changer ça vous avez le
président si si qui va bientôt arriver
en france il arrive le président
égyptien arrive lundi en en france qui a
dans son discours à la mosquée d'al
azhar a dit qu'il fallait que la
religion et intègre à la sphère privée
et qui va avec l'islam sunnite pense à
se réformer alors que lui même est un
pieu un musulman donc ça c'est important
mais mon sentiment mon sentiment c'est
qu'en fait vous avez comme un grand
bassin à cause de tous ses pétrodollars
wahhabisme qui était exporté un grand
bassin de salafistes et deux frères
musulmans dans l'islam n'y a pas que ça
bien sûr mais il ya un grand bassin deux
frères musulmans et de salafistes et mon
problème c'est que pour moi
un jihadiste c'est un salafiste ou c'est
un frère musulman que vous voudrez en
phase terminale ces derniers jusqu'au
bout de son engagement